as a side note let me say that this
conversation with Bhaskar Sankara who's
a brilliant socialist writer and
philosopher represents what I hope to do
with this podcast I hope to talk to the
left and the right to the far left and
the far right always with the goal of
presenting and understanding both the
strongest interpretation of their ideas
and valuable thought-provoking arguments
against those ideas
also I hope to understand the human
being behind the ideas
I trust in your intelligence as The
Listener to use the ideas you hear to
help you learn to think to empathize and
to make up your own mind
I will often fall short in pushing back
too hard or not pushing back enough
of uh not bringing up topics I should
have of talking too much of interrupting
too much or or maybe sometimes in the
rare case is not enough of being too
silly on a serious topic or being too
serious on a silly topic I'm trying to
do my best and I will keep working my
ass off to improve
in this way I hope to talk to prominent
figures in the political space even
controversial ones on both the left and
the right for example I hope to talk to
Donald Trump and Alexandria
ocasio-cortez
Toronto Santos and Barack Obama and of
course many others across the political
Spectrum
I sometimes hear accusations about me
being controlled in some way by a
government or an intelligence agency
like CIA FSB Massad or perhaps that I'm
controlled in some way by the very human
desire for money Fame power access
all I have is my silly little words
but let me give them to you
I'm not and will never be controlled by
anyone there's nothing in this world
that can break me and force me to
sacrifice my integrity
people call me naive
I'm not naive I'm optimistic and
optimism isn't a passive state of being
it's a constant battle against the world
that wants to pull you into a downward
spiral of cynicism to me optimism is
freedom
freedom to think to act to build to help
at times in the face of impossible odds
as I often do please allow me to read a
few lines from the poem If by Roger
Kipling
if you can keep your head when all about
you are losing theirs and blaming it on
you
if you can trust yourself and all men
doubt you but make allowance for their
doubting too
if you can wait and not be tired by
waiting or being lied about don't deal
in lies or being hated don't give way to
hating and yet don't look too good don't
talk too wise
even this very poem is mocking my over
romantic Ridiculousness as I read it the
meta irony is not lost on me my friends
I'm a silly little kid trying to do a
bit of good in this world
thank you for having my back through all
of it all of my mistakes
thank you for the love
this is the Lex Friedman podcast
um
to support it
please check out our sponsors in the
description and now dear friends